why not follow up Kyle like if you write
to someone or contact their people and
you don't hear back or what if you hear
a no is it is it then bad form to then
go back again and try to push I don't
think so i think it does always matter
being you have to know that it's their
job to say no you know it's an agent's
job to say to say no they're protecting
their client and they probably get a lot
of requests so you have to be respectful
of them but persistent but also then at
that point you know for me you know his
representation who've been incredibly
supportive of the product I don't have a
single bad thing to say about there's
like look it's this policy to say no we
really appreciate it but he said no to
film projects and for me at that point I
was like well this is different and I
want to communicate to him how this was
different but you know I had a finished
film and so I just went to one of his
book readings and handed him a copy of
the film I didn't try to pitch him
myself there anything I mean he was Davy
Rothbart was of this american life
colleague of his they knew each other
and so i could be like hey I made this
movie about Davey Roth bar if you like
it I'd like to talk to you you know and
I saw it for me it's it's just always
about staying respectful and knowing why
people especially if the author is more
well known what no know why they have a
system around them you know and if and
trust that but also trust your instincts
if you feel like I just need a chance to
talk to them or you know sometimes
that's where I find if you write a
letter you know if you write like a
personal letter usually it's the
representations imperative to at least
pass that letter on you know they
usually won't it'll take a really
cynical agent to tear up a letter you
know what I mean and not pass it on if
you mean it sincerely so you know it's
less about getting an answer and more
about doing enough that makes you feel
like you know once i had to david the
copy of the movie for me that was my
line that was like as far as I would go
with it invited I will I sent a letter
through his representation and I gave
him a copy of my film that a reading of
his at that point moving on if I never
heard from him I would have achieved
peace with it you know that I felt like
that was enough and I'd if I got to know
or never even heard anything for me I
pushed enough so I think just knowing
when when you pushed enough is important
well what is that line between
polite persistence and then just being
obnoxiously pushy what's that doing a
great r in the radio at paranoid android
that radiohead song he says ambition
makes you look pretty ugly you know it's
one of those things it's like yeah you
can I think you just need to know I
think you need to just learn how to read
people and and know when it's too i
don't know where that is its instincts
maybe sometimes I've been on the other
side of it you know in the wrong side of
it you know I I try to you know there's
it's a fine line between ugly ambition
and persistence and I think it's just
kidding just trusting your own gut any
situations probably differently I think
so yeah
you